welcome to my talk which apparently my
naming joke was also simultaneously
thought of by Laurence Moroney if you
went to his talk or two hours ago but
it's a clever one the goal today is to
walk through everything you need to
understand in order to be able to
understand how jobscheduler works
because if you can know how to choose
between different options with building
a background task if it'll just build a
better app which will be really great
but jobscheduler is really scary and
nobody ever wants to talk about it
because if you bring it up and somebody
starts talking to you you probably won't
understand what they're talking about
and that's hard so we're gonna go
through all of it and by the end of this
you're gonna walk out of here like ready
to name-drop jobscheduler and like just
really ramp it and like advocate for it
so it'll be great why you should listen
to me I am Joanna Smith this is a copy
of my bio off the website you can read
that or not but specifically the things
I've done with Android I co-founded the
Android development patterns initiative
and so we have a lot of videos me and
Ian like these right there
you probably just watched his talk we
made the videos and we have a weekly
protip series of written content and we
have a lot more ideas coming over the
next year where we're trying to we're
trying to identify you know bust bad
behavior and teach best practices
because we have a lot of developer
outreach on how Android works and how
API is work and really like how you can
implement but we don't have anyone
telling you when to implement or what to
choose or what the options are or like
if you have 13 different paths which
one's gonna be best for your app and so
we're trying to tackle that problem
watch a video to let us know how well
we're doing and then also we created the
second course in our Udacity android
nanodegree so if you're trying to like
expand your skills or just brush up on
something you haven't seen before that's
a really great resource
all those course materials are available
online for free but if you like enroll
in the class and pay the fee you also
get like an instructor guidance so
that's pretty cool and then this is just
like a fun fact list to throw out there
I started learning Android actually in
February of 2014 so I'm very new to this
game compared to a lot of people and I
like to bring that up because it can
seem really intimidating when you're
learning something new and you're trying
to get into it and everyone's talking
about all these words that you don't
understand and you know they're you know
reminiscing back to like how gingerbread
was so ugly and you're like I don't even
think I ever had a gingerbread phone
like I don't know how to participate in
this conversation and it's intimidating
and this is a hard hard problem to solve
and I just want everyone to know like
you don't I mean like I do this less
than two years ago and I'm
giving a talk to you guys as if I met
experts like you can really learn a lot
really fast if you just kind of like
push yourself and try so that being said
let's try background services the goal
here is we want to do a bunch of work
off of our main thread and because that
main thread it's also called the UI
thread for a very good reason meaning
that it controls everything that you can
see on the device so if something starts
to go wrong and you're still on your UI
thread your user is just going to see
this hideous thing don't be this it's
ugly I couldn't even find a good picture
of it because nobody wants to screenshot
it it's such a horrifying sight right
and I don't know how to make one so know
if you're if you if you show this to
your user if this comes up your user is
immediately giving up on you they're
leaving the app they're not trying again
they're not going to try to refresh most
likely they won't open you up again and
they'll probably even uninstall you like
this is a death warrant and you don't
want to see this but the thing is that's
what users see what it actually means is
that your app is working really hard and
it just needs a minute and that's what's
really frustrating because the developer
perspective here is that you know you're
you're trying to do work and you just
forgot something but the user
perspective is you're the worst ever and
I hate you so we're gonna move on and
we're going to avoid this by moving
something off the main thread work
that's gonna hang it's gonna make us
miss our framerate and we don't want to
do that so we're gonna just shift it
away and then it can resync with the
later activity when it's time to
actually update it instead of trying to
like pause the current activity and wait
for it okay so that's our goal so we
don't want to miss our framerate because
we missed that Colt McAnlis will just
magically appear and start hating on you
so the question is where do we start
and when I say background work all of
you're probably thinking oh good a sync
task and that's not correct an async
task is actually tied to your activity
lifecycle and that can be I can have its
own advantages and disadvantages
so I'm going to focus on work that is
entirely off the main thread and async
tasks like has its place and you can you
know read all about it on your own so
let's start with services
what's a service well its complex
they're hard they have a lot of pieces
you have to manage services run in the
background they're fully apart from any
app activity or fragment but that means
that it can keep running even when your
app isn't which is actually pretty
fantastic but because of this button
but services can't affect your UI so you
know if you actually want to show a
progress dialog because what you're
doing is in the response to a user
initiated action you probably do want
your async task but that's a really
great way to do it but if you're kicking
off some sort of activity that only
needs to report back when it's done and
like maybe update the UI then like a
service is going to be great because it
can send that information back like
through other avenues later on but yeah
you can't update the UI while you're in
a service so when your results seep to
pass it services are great for things
like syncing with your server this is
something that's not usually user
initiated but you want to like backup
all those photos they've been taking in
your app like that's really important
but that doesn't have to happen exactly
at that moment that could happen when
the phone is put down or is idle or you
know just whenever there's a chance and
the radios already on the other thing is
that services have to manage their own
life cycle and that can be kind of
intimidating because you have to first
figure out which methods to override and
then how to override them and then what
you want to leave alone and then how you
call it and then that's just a lot which
goes back to my point that services are
complex so that's why we're gonna talk
about intent service which does all this
work for you like how nice is that
so an instant service isn't much easier
implementation because it will handle
all of its own life cycle you don't have
to worry about starting it or binding it
or letting it go or just trying it like
it's it does all of that for you it's
already written you can focus on what
matters and that's the background work
and not how you get into or out of your
background tasks the trade-off here with
an intent service and something other
one is that an intent service can only
handle one thing at a time all requests
will happen sequentially so if your app
is designed with multiple requests that
might come in and all need to exit at
the same time you're gonna have to read
the documentation on how services work
sorry okay so how do we create an intent
service first step is you know you have
to make a class for your service and to
do that you need to declare it in your
manifest you have to say that this is
going to be here like this actually
exists and I'm going to use it and then
of course some of you may know export it
is this variable that says you can like
restrict to your app the service to only
being accessed by your app which is what
false means or if you say to true other
apps may be able to interact with your
service and set it off with just
sometimes really valuable
you can also declare multiple services
you can have like 13 of them and each
one is a very targeted
service like definitely a real service
could be like definitely a real share
service and you have like definitely a
real backup service and everyone could
have its own specified tasks which makes
code main it's really easy and also
means it's a lot easier to track what's
going on and what things are going wrong
but most importantly your service needs
to extend from intense service so here
you have got your class and the only
method you have to implement or override
by default is on handle intent you can
actually just ignore all the other ones
that's that whole lifecycle being
handled for you thing which is pretty
fantastic so on handle intent this is
where all of your work is going to
happen imagine that so maybe this is
where you're going to open a network
connection or send data to your server
and then you know clean up that
connection that would be pretty great
you know cleaning up your network
connections or maybe you want to write
to the SD card all of this kind of stuff
is like definitely not supposed to
affect your UI like maybe you'll send
the message like you know updated and
like change to something of the green
but all of the data you might need you
can put into that intent like as an
extra pass it along and then use that to
maybe kick off a notification or kick
off the work that you need to do
anything that's really relevant the
service is pretty versatile so once
you've got it written you need to invoke
it and this happens from usually an
activity and to do that you need to
create the intent fill it with something
and then pass it and passing it is great
you just call start service it's
actually that easy like okay started I'm
ready like I said like intent service
manages its own life cycle you don't
have to like start it bind it all that
end stuff you just call start service
with the intent and you're done
like that's actually all there is to it
and then with all of the data you passed
along then your intent might be your
service might be able actually use that
same kind of intent to report back so
give it enough information to know what
its job is and if a response isn't
necessary - okay so you know that you
can use it with calling start service
but the question is when to call start
service and my advice is usually from a
broadcast receiver because these are
really great ways of waiting for a
signal that something needs to happen
whenever like whenever anything actually
that needs to happen so a broadcast
receivers job is to respond to an
announcement and that comes in the form
of yet another intent like these are
magical little things of like I'd like
to do this with these constraints so
intent is a common trigger for kicking
off background work but which is great
because a broadcast receiver
doesn't actually bring your app into the
foreground it can kick off a service
that may or may not affect foreground
work but like the broadcast receiver
itself opens like runs on receive and
then triggers whatever's in that and
then stays all in the background so
you're still protecting your main thread
which is our goal here
okay so broadcast receivers can actually
interact with several different sources
like a local broadcast will come from
within your own app and this is a sign
that maybe it's time to sync oh it's
going to kick off the service or maybe
it's actually the intent service
reporting back about how the job winds
are like you know this failed or that
that's not a real URI app broadcast can
also come from other apps on the device
which is really great when you're trying
to take advantage of functionality that
you don't want to build but somebody
else offers or you want to offer
functionality to other developers so
that you actually get users using a lot
of different really great things you
don't have to keep rebuilding you know
picture-taking every time right or
storage or something like that system
broadcasts are really important they
carry status information things like
something being plugged in or like a
signal that's changing something you
might be subscribed to so if you really
care about you know your app only runs
when plugged in because maybe your sleep
tracker and you don't want it to fall
asleep like wow the users also sleep
that's the kind thing you like wait for
the signal on this and then if came
unplugged you'd get a broadcast that
it's unplugged and that might change
your behavior you might like only stop
tracking data to that point and finally
you can use them for serve our messages
like downstream messages GCM actually
has its own dedicated broadcast receiver
system which I'll tell you about doctor
has done stream messages are a great way
for your server to indicate that
something needs to happen now which the
app might not be able to give a signal
on right and so any kind of message so
basically broadcast receivers are the
best thing ever because any kind of
message can come through and then you
can react accordingly and maybe start
off any kind of different service and
just like a service you can register
multiple receivers so let's talk about
how to do that
with an intent service is the same thing
you have to create the actual class and
then declare it your receiver in your
manifest looks roughly the same but the
meet of everything here is going to live
in this method called on receive it's
really the only thing you have to
override with a broadcast receiver and
this will do all of your intent
processing like you get the intent that
comes through and any extras might
indicate what what kind of work you're
doing here maybe your broadcast receiver
does double duty maybe it doesn't but
this will
like I'll help you do any kind of
processing and kicking off at your
service the thing about a broadcast
receiver is that it only lives for the
duration of this on receive call which
is like milliseconds so you can't do
your Korra if your background work in
here you need to offload that to prevent
any further hanging because otherwise as
soon as this call completes a dice like
also if you have like a helper method
like you just don't really have a chance
here okay so you also have to register
your broadcast receiver like you have to
say which intents you're interested in
so you don't just get everything like
that would be a nightmare like just
constant information coming in and I
recommend looking into what's called
local broadcast manager because if
you're really just using broadcast
within your own app as a signal to and
from services this is a great tool you
can also include like an intent filter
be like Olympus intent with these kinds
of parameters and stuff so let's do set
up everything for a number of situations
and I think it's pretty great so check
the docs on that because we're going to
move on to what's called a wakeful
broadcast receiver I told you that on
receive only lasts look your app is only
brought to life like the duration of on
receive which means that there's a
chance that between on receive and start
service like on receive wraps and your
service hasn't started that there's a
chance that the system might take away
your CPU time in between that so if you
need to guarantee that your service runs
the moment that on receive ends you want
to acquire a way clock and you want to
hold that way clock until your service
has a chance to run but way clocks are
hard and you shouldn't have to waste
your time on that because we did it for
you we created the wakeful broadcast
receiver which manages its own way
o'clock and still guarantees that your
service will run immediately after on
receive so again look at all these
things we did for you because background
work is really hard let us manage it as
much of the life cycle as we can unless
you have some sort of custom situation
and at that point you already doing tons
of research so you're golden right okay
so implementing we call a flow progress
to see we're look it's exactly the same
except I added the word wakeful like
it's not scary at all it's the only
change it's just I mean I'm serious like
all these things we worked really hard
finally to like make these like great
tools for you because it wasn't easy for
so long okay so I mentioned that GCM has
its own special situation and I'd like
to explain a little bit more about that
we really try to push GCM
not just because we like love our own
products but because if you have to
maintain a persistent network connection
on a device that's expensive it drains
Radio it drains CPU time it drains the
battery and so if every app is trying to
do their own homegrown version that's
going to be horrible but if we can
create one that the entire device knows
about that's like smart enough to know
when to pass things along to the right
apps and has the right access things
then we can save huge performance wins
huge user wins and huge developer effort
right and that's why you can see us
we're always pushing Google Cloud
messaging the other thing is that GM has
an advantage that your homegrown version
will never have and that's that all of
our carriers have worked with us to give
like special recognition to the port's
that GCM travels on to keep them open as
long as possible right and so any g-sync
like any messaging alternative that
you'll see it'll read on stream
messaging will usually be built on top
of GCM or will be built on like a
polling system and you don't if you
don't want to build your own polling
system why would you want to build on
top of another one right so throughout
the conference as you see us all
basically force-feeding you juicing them
know that we have a really good reason
for it it's not just because we happen
to be the cousins with it okay so the
other thing about GCM receiver is it
actually extends from wakeful broadcast
receiver so you get that way clock
management by default which is even
better so to use it you have to declare
your receiver the way you would any way
any other receiver except you have to
have a something special which is the
permission to send that means that you
are basically adhering to the permission
required by GCM because it will you want
you want protected communications so GCM
service requires this permission and you
honor that permission and that's what
this lets you do declare it in your
manifest and then also you set up an
instant filter to say like I want all
receiving messages from GCM to my
application right super easy okay so
then you build your listener service you
look Patino so you don't have to build a
receiver you don't have to extend from
GCM receiver like that already exists
for you you just have to use it by
declaring it and then all you have to do
is override your listener service it's
not an intent service but it's still
pretty great because you don't have to
manage any lifecycle still and then your
message comes in with like who it's from
so you get your server ID you can double
check that like you're getting it from
right message in case maybe you have
multiple different things and you get
all the information you need in data
based on how you structure your own data
when you send it
so great so great why are you not doing
this okay so now we can move on from how
background works specifically is like
goes like how to implement it to when to
implement it and how to invoke it right
like you know that you can call start
service but the question is like what do
you really use to trigger a reminder
when it comes later and like when when
does it need to come later so
considering that question of when if you
need your work to run at a specific
moment in time you're going to get to
meet the alarm manager so an alarm is
not like a wake-up alarm like doing an
evening alarm is a signal to your app
that it's time for your app to wake up
and do some more work and when you
register an intent with an alarm it'll
actually fire that intent as soon as it
fires through the alarm manager so
setting alarms with alarm manager just
had a single alarm with anything that's
above API 19 you can call set look how
simple that is and it sets a single and
exact alarm and what in exact means is
that let's say your alarms mr. golf like
in an hour it will not go off before
that hour but it may go off sometime
after that hour if the system is trying
to intelligently batch things together
right because we want to we want to save
battery as much as possible so if we
know that there are four alarms coming
up sometime between 3 & 4 we might try
to run them all at the same time but it
will never fire early and that's a
guarantee we also have set window which
is if you're flexible and you don't
really mind using set like you want to
have a definite like a duration of time
this is pretty great because you can
specify what that window is going to be
and then for when it really does matter
we have set an exact in order to specify
that time actually really does matter
and this is important for maybe like a
calendar reminder if you're 40 minutes
late on that you've actually really
messed up with your users life the other
thing to note is that any API before 19
set inset exact or equivalent because
we've been actually introduced in exact
timing until KitKat so you api's before
19 you just call set and it's already
exact how great is that
ok so to do this look how few lines of
code this is like this isn't terrifying
like you don't have to worry you just
you know get the alarmmanager service
from the system create your intent and
you have to turn your intent into a
pending intent and that's how this the
alarm manager is able to actually fire
it definitely is request codes here
so I'm skipping you could you could call
a receiver here that would make a lot of
sense because maybe you want to react to
like a different kind of thing
I'm just leaping straight to the surface
like I know that this alarm means it's
time to run this thing I'm just gonna
invoke that service directly and then I
set it up for whenever I wanted to go
time to sugar
I didn't declare that because I don't
know why I'm here maybe I want to be in
an hour okay different situation maybe
you don't want a single alarm maybe you
want alarm that repeats itself on like
on its own schedule this is surprisingly
still alarm manager you're not surprised
it's not a surprise okay so with
repeating alarms we have nothing on set
an exact repeating for guess what an
exact repeating alarms so you specify a
period of time like maybe you need it to
go off every hour but not necessarily on
the hour you have a little bit of get
there so we'll go off every hour but you
know maybe maybe at 15 maybe not which
is pretty fantastic as far as like I
need this to be done fairly regularly
but I don't specifically care that it's
at 4:02 p.m. and then that means that
you can you know talk about set exact
repeating except this doesn't exist
that's not a thing we didn't create that
because it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense we actually say use set exact to
set a repeating alarm and then when it
triggers that one set the next one
because if it's that exact you probably
have something else you care about and
you probably want to check on that the
other truth is we actually don't really
recommend this either we'd rather you
just not set exact repeating alarms at
all so setting an exact repeating is
really your answer but if you can need a
special use case just do it one at a
time and build that into how you manage
your alarm so to set an exact repeating
alarm you see how it's pretty much
exactly the same as far as setting it up
and then you call set in things like
repeating but instead of just saying the
time to trigger you have to add that
interval that the interval that you
really care about again I just made up a
variable because I don't specifically
care about counting up milliseconds
right now now what if you need your
alarm to go off often like let's say
every 60 seconds right like it's
something that triggers another action
maybe so you're checking in on a sensor
or like there's something that you need
to do incredibly incredibly often we
don't recommend al our manager at all we
think you should write your own handler
to handle this kind of thing and use a
time trigger but I'm not going to teach
you how to do that because that's really
bad for performance and battery you
should probably try to find an altar
instead but you should not exist okay
now when your job needs to go off at
some point today
maybe ish like just whenever we're on
Wi-Fi like either when you don't really
care you just want it to happen or when
you're waiting for a specific set of
conditions team it this is when you're
going to get to that wonderful thing
that's called job scheduler and you're
not afraid right because you have all
this background you're like not
intimidated anymore
okay so job scheduler isn't complicated
it's just got a lot of pieces to it so
let's talk about background it was
introduced in lollipop and what it does
is it doesn't work off of a time
schedule the way in an alarm does it
said it works about based off of
conditions like maybe I'm waiting for a
Wi-Fi when the user isn't actually using
their phone like that's a pretty good
time to run a upload of photos right
Java's Euler is designed to make it
really easy for the system to batch jobs
because everybody says I have this job
it needs to happen at this this like
kind of situation and I have one too and
you're like oh great you're both want
Wi-Fi Wi-Fi is on let's go together like
hold hands you've got a buddy and that's
our battery and perf win which will make
Colt McAnlis really happy the other
thing is Java scheduler surprisingly
runs on the main thread and I'm not
really kidding like the job service that
you create will run on your main thread
so when you're actually doing
complicated work use your job service in
conjunction with some other background
service like a task an async task or
like an intent service right right okay
so to use job scheduler you start by
creating that job service that runs on
the main thread which is very odd in my
mind
to do this you need to override at least
two methods if not more the first is on
start' job which is called not by you
but by the system when it's time to
start your job but because it runs on
the main thread this is the place where
you want to kick off to your other work
when you're doing heavy computations if
you're just setting a job to maybe send
a notification because it's like six
o'clock and it's reminded that's fine
but like anything that's like heavy you
want to kick it off here and when you
overhead on cert job in addition to
starting whatever workers you need to
return a boolean so you're going to
return true if you've moved work to a
background thread in order to you know
perform that kind of stuff
to show that something else is going on
in job scheduling needs to be aware
but you returned false if it was a
simple task and you've already finished
and we're done processing so that's what
that boolean means and then for onstart
job I'm sorry for onstop job you
actually this is called by the system
again but it's only with the job is
canceled before it gets a chance to be
finished so maybe you were waiting for a
Wi-Fi and then you had it but the user
left the Wi-Fi zone and now you don't
have it anymore but you haven't finished
so we cancelled the job because you know
this conditions aren't being met anymore
and so this is about this boolean is for
whatever cleanup you need to do is
important but also you need to return
true if you want to reschedule that job
because it didn't have a chance to run
but if it didn't really matter then you
can return false and it will just be
dropped so that's what those super
indicative boolean's are and then that
third method that you don't override but
you need to call that lives inside of
job services job finished and this is
how you call it
you need to in your service like way
away that you've kicked off - once
you're done with your work you call this
and you pass back the job parameters
that were passed in you see from here
you're on staff job so I included a
minute up but you need to pass those
parameters back to indicate which job
we're finished with and this tells the
system that we actually completed like
we're good we're very very happy and
we're done and you don't have to worry
about Reese so your scheduling unless
you failed at your job maybe like the
network connection fell through or
something on your servers end and so
that's what that boolean here means so
true means we need to reschedule with a
job and false means that work and
rescheduling true will kick off job
scheduler has a built-in exponential
back-off for you you don't have to do
that math you don't have to like track
of like when when you want to retry like
will do that intelligently on your
behalf we just know that you didn't
succeed and you want to try again and so
we'll reschedule you look how helpful we
are okay
I like how thought about it we like I
didn't work on this I just know how to
use it you need to register your service
as usual but you also need to bind to
the job service and so yet another
permission that's nested in with our
declaration and finally you create the
scheduler so this is going to be
probably in an activity wherever you're
keeping track of your thing and there's
a couple pieces here so second bit of
this is the job scheduler we're just
fetching that from the system again very
easy and then we create a job
info object and that needs some sort of
ID for the job so that your activity
knows what's going on but also the name
of the service so for the first time
we're not using an intent to rely on
we're just using the class name which we
get from the component name class and
then all of the conditions you care
about and I'll touch on that in just a
minute and then he just called scheduler
schedule with your job info very very
easy so the hard part is with job info
and these are like just some of the
offering as a job in front offers so
these I told you you could decide you
only care about certain criteria and
this is where you can set all of those
criteria when you're like worried about
your job
okay so couple these are pretty obvious
like you can create your own back off
and retry policy and then that'll be
used when we're rescheduling your job
for you you can create a minimum delay
before your job is run so if you say
like I want to do this whenever I click
whenever Wi-Fi is on but I don't want to
do it until at least six hours from now
like that can be really helpful
especially if you're managing traffic
with your server we have an override
deadline so it's the maximum amount of
time that can pass before your job must
be run that's really helpful to like if
you you know that you have to get
something done today and it's gonna hit
midnight or whatever persistent
indicates that you want to persist this
job request across the reboot a lot of
times like when your app is like started
for the first time then you know you
might change to your behavior but if you
know that you need this like after the
reboot but like that'll be that's a
great way to indicate it then we have
connectivity requirements it could be
you're waiting for any you network
metered or or not or maybe you're just
waiting for Wi-Fi specifically and so
you've got some constants in the class
that will help you specify that and then
of course charging and our idle idle
indicating that the screen is off
usually okay so this is this is the
magic of job scheduler this is like
where it happens and then we have this
hypothetical situation of you know like
do I just use one and I would say you
know no so what if you have a situation
where you user press as a share button
like it's off your intent service
because the share probably needs to
happen right away that's user initiated
but you're not actually online for some
reason like maybe it's a bad connection
or maybe you can release a HP so you
could then use your intense service to
schedule a job scheduled like a job
service for you right and then that way
you don't have to worry again about
keeping track of your own
back off for your own retry you don't
have to worry about like what's going on
you can just be like okay I failed when
I try to do it immediately the user
probably when I was since they're not on
internet anyway so let's just schedule
is for later and this is just one of
those things for like it's hard to teach
like how do you teach someone to
consider multiple different resources to
build the best possible behavior this is
one that like I was talking about my my
talking even was like well you know like
you should tell him about like fun
things I was like I didn't even think of
that like how do I stand up here and
teach people if I can't even think of
all these things and so it is hard and
that's why I really like when you know
people share about this ghost because
like this would be a great situation and
it makes things so much easier for the
developer like you can use these kinds
of services not just to take work off
the main thread but also to make it so
you don't have to build your own logic
that's been built 17,000 times already
okay so trying to teach you how to build
better apps and also not how to how to
not work very hard this is gonna be
really successful you guys the final
point I want to touch on is what about
actual alarms like those ones that go
ding ding ding and wake you up from your
nap
right if alarmmanager manages the other
alarms like how do you actually schedule
these like those seem really important
like do I have to like issue my own
sound notification or something every
time my alarm manager goes off and the
thing is no you don't because all our
manager has this super helpful set alarm
clock method and then of course you can
get the next time clock but that's
introduced in 21 clearly since I wrote
that on the thing so what's special
about these methods as they were
introduced relatively cently and also
these will these are exempt from any
kind of doze mode or abstain by idle
mode that we've introduced because alarm
clocks are incredibly important like the
user probably relies on those for you
know getting to work on time and so
what's really cool about these two
method are not do ones just to let you
know the next one is but what's really
cool about set alarm clock is that if
you set that alarm let's say for like
6:30 in the morning and you're in doze
mode because you forgot to charge your
phone over night or whatever those modal
exit well before 6:30 to give every app
a chance to run and sync so when the
user finally hears that noise and wakes
up and checks their phone like
everything's ready like the news is
already there and so I think that's a
really cool build around so you can
definitely rely on these if you're using
if you're not quite to 21 but you're on
KitKat
you can just you know call settle exact
you know because we're not worried about
doze because you're on an older phone
but you know exactly that this time is
going to happen because that exact will
be honored and then finally for before
kick at you can just use set directly
because we didn't introduce in exact
anything until after that and so that's
how you would cover actual important
alarms and that's my whole talk other
things you probably want to look into
our sync adapters which will help you
manage data programmatically on your own
and also we have GCM network manager so
if you want to look at something similar
to drop scheduler but is a little bit
more targeted you should read that
documentation but hey now you're all job
scheduler pros right like you could
totally do this on your own
right right that's not a very
enthusiastic thank you Alex okay cool
this is how you can find me on Google+
and on Twitter if you have any questions
always feel free to economy I will
honestly try to respond to them I'm bad
at social networking but I'm working on
it and I will be mingling in this room
if you have any other questions about
how to do this but hopefully you're not
scared of background jobs and services
the way I was last year